well it happened again this week a drag
show at a high school hosted by that
school's so-called gay straight alliance
this time it was ann kenny high school
in iowa cross-dressing males were
brought up on stage in the school's
auditorium to gyrate around on stage in
their woman face makeup and absurd
outfits according to the daily wire
report one of the performers also
delivered a speech about his gender
transition he told the kids in
attendance quote when i felt like i
couldn't express myself in school or i
felt like i had to look like this at
school
i could be whoever i wanted to be and i
started to think what is gender and i
realize that no matter what pronouns you
use you are who you are i know on the
inside that i am who i am
now it doesn't mean anything of course
but it's not supposed to mean anything
there is a message here but it's not one
that is communicated through
intelligible coherent sentences most of
the time
libs of tick tock which first published
the videos of this event
says that students um the the minors at
the school were also brought up on stage
to dance
so for the school's part they say that
this was not an official school event
and that it was not conducted in
accordance with their policies
it is under investigation they say they
want to make sure that the drag show was
in accordance with their policies uh
looks like it might not have been
but it's of course impossible to believe
that the auditorium was used for a drag
show and the administrators didn't know
about it or that they did know about it
but they didn't know what a drag show
entails
that's that seems to be kind of what
they're claiming that uh that they saw
the videos and they're like oh that's a
drag show well that's clearly we we
don't want that
but they're feigning ignorance of course
which is the same thing that happened a
week or two earlier when a different
high school this one in pennsylvania
notice the states involved here iowa
pennsylvania okay not not uh
washington vermont california although
these things are certainly happening in
those states as well
but uh they held their own gsa sponsored
drag show grown men in makeup wigs
thongs performed a burlesque routine for
children at hempfield high school
this is certainly not something that any
mentally stable person wants to see
particularly right around lunchtime but
i'm going to play some of the footage
for you anyway because uh you need to
understand just how over the top
creepily sexual this was uh
here it is
[Music]
okay
surprising enough of that
so you get the you get the gist
uh nothing to see there just a grown man
and a thong on all fours shaking his ass
for a group of school children
the administrators in this case say that
they were appalled by what took place
but coincidentally they were only
appalled when parents found out about it
and complained
a teacher named kelly tyson who's an
advisor for the gsa club
expressed her delight and joy in
watching this pedophilic display but she
also confessed to something else
inadvertently which is quite damning for
the school administration she wrote in a
social media post quote i don't know how
to explain the sheer joy i feel in my
bones when these queens come take time
out of their busy schedules to perform
for us year three
and to be with my students as gsa
co-advisor and a queer teacher it makes
me emotional to think of this space
we've created i would have loved nothing
more than have a space like they have an
opportunity to attend their own drag
show
year three she says
so they've been doing this for uh three
years and the administration just
noticed how appalling it is
that's what we're supposed to believe
and it's obviously total nonsense so
what is actually going on here and
what's with the leftist obsession with
drag in particular
they've got drag queens story hour drag
shows at high schools drag shows at all
their gay pride events drag shows on tv
drag reality shows
why
along with all the other problems with
this stuff i mean the many many problems
especially when kids are involved
it's not even like these dudes are
talented dancers or performers they're
just weird-looking guys and ugly outfits
dancing badly on stage what's the point
i mean even if it was only adults in the
audience
why would anyone want to see that
why has drag in particular become such a
central component of the left's culture
war strategy i think there are a few
reasons for that
it's worth thinking about one
drag contributes to the sort of
costumification
if i can coin my own word of womanhood
the drag performer makes womanhood into
this
cartoonish gaudy ridiculous thing he
turns it into a stage performance a
costume it's no surprise that the drag
queen uh at the one school event gave a
speech about gender identity and talked
about how drag helped him get in touch
with his inner female identity because
this is how the left sees womanhood they
see it as a cheap degraded
hyper-sexualized thing which is
interchangeable and superficial and can
be taken off just as easily as it's put
on
that's one reason why they love drag
because of of of what it does to
womanhood how it portrays womanhood how
it cheapens it that's what they like
about it
uh also
drag is an assault not only on
femininity but also on beauty and
anything that assaults femininity also
assaults beauty
it is a protest against traditional
notions of beauty womanhood and so on
everything the left does is targeted to
tear down whatever they think is
traditional as traditional to them is
synonymous with archaic or oppressive
and when these drag performances are
staged for children
it's also meant to tear down and sever
the parent-child relationship the author
carl truman who appears by the way in my
film what is a woman premiering june 1st
uh which is next wednesday make sure
you're there get your membership um he
made this point an interview with the
daily wire published today which is very
interesting and worth going to read the
whole thing
but he says quoting from him he says
children are the perfect targets for
groups whose purpose is the subversion
of subversion of the parent-child bond
and the consequent strengthening of the
power of a progressive establishment
destroy the bond between parents and
children and you have destroyed the most
powerful and influential pre-political
bond of influence and loyalty that
stands in the way of various lobby
groups trying to drive the direction of
our culture
i couldn't have said it better myself
but there's one other factor to consider
here and that is
cowardice
okay there's a there's a whole lot of
cowardice
that leads to things like this happening
in our schools
the administrators
are of course lying when they claim
ignorance they know that this sort of
thing is going on
every time a teacher is exposed for
grooming indoctrinating children the
administrators know about it they knew
about it before that it's never subtle i
mean you see all these tick tock videos
that they're posting first of all
they're posting tick tock videos they're
not hiding it
and then you see they've got all these
excuses they always have rainbow flags
draped all over their classrooms
you know and they've got the purple hair
and rainbow earrings it's like they've a
walking advertisement saying this is the
only thing i care about this is all i
talk to my kids about
not hiding their intentions
so do the people in charge go along with
this
because they are themselves lgbt
radicals intent on grooming children in
some cases yes certainly
but especially if we're talking about a
situation in california or vermont or uh
washington state or something like that
then then it's it's very likely that
everybody involved if we're talking
about a school isn't is an lgbt radical
but at a school in iowa
are the administrators a bunch of lgbt
extremists
maybe but probably not
they simply lack the courage to tell the
lgbt extremists to cool it knock it off
keep the crap out of the classroom
they know better some of them
they don't have the backbone to stand up
to the lgbt bullies so they let them do
whatever they want and i do mean
whatever they want
until the backlash from outside
forces their hand
so this is the the formula
lgbt extremism
and the cowardice that enables it
add that together and you get
cross-dressing adult men twerking on
stage for children
and you get a whole lot more besides
that
and none of it of course is good
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content